[Music]
hello everyone so you might have seen
the talk from cat just before it's
really interesting and you should keep
it in mind while we make this one as
there are a few things that might
overlap a bit
so first Who am I my name is Maya I used
to work for the past two years and a
half at Facebook as part of the
JavaScript foundation team my job there
was to maintain the infrastructure used
by JavaScript engineers and as part of
this I came to contribute to young and
even though I'm not for long a part of
Facebook I'm still managing Yann
as time passed I started to take more
and more responsibilities on the project
and Here I am today talking about the
work we've been doing for the v2 which
is in no small part based on my
observation after using yarn at scale
for a few years something I'd like to
remember when doing this kind of talk is
why does Yann exist in the first place
how did it get created it all started
with three companies Facebook Google and
Expo which felt like something was
missing in their infrastructure they
figured that the existing solution
didn't meet all their needs internal
stability performance and user
experience and so they decided to try
something different to try something new
a different solution with different
architectural choices different
trade-offs that should would still be
compatible with the ecosystem at large
that was a huge mad but I think we
largely succeeded and that's how young
got created since then we kept this
philosophy and I think of yarn as a kind
of laboratory we try things we
experiment and find new solution
speaking of features before talking
about you what young too will bring to
the table in 2019 and beyond we must
first go quickly over what is already
contributed and more importantly what
all the things he did right that's
important to know because that's how we
can ensure that we won't lose what makes
our core values when we make the
transition from the v1 to the v2 and
this is an open question by the way I
would very much like to hear what you
think
Yann did what so please come see me
after the talk and share your stories
that's the fuel we used to make yarn
what it is
ever since young got created something
we deemed very important was stability
we won't JavaScript project to be stable
we want you to trust your project and
we're ready to get the extra mile to
achieve this goal
our firm this is achieved by teaching
good practices and letting you know when
something is wrong before it can even
cause any arm so we were to remove
unsafe patterns from the equation as
much as possible our log files ensure
that the install dependency is always
the same
our install strategy plug-and-play
prevents all wasting to suddenly cause
your application to break a deploy time
and our offline mirror ensures that the
network will never be a problem in
deployment speaking of the network this
is one thing in particular that we
worked really well for us
at Facebook we barely even noticed when
the registry was down in fact we often
learned about it through Twitter too
through tweets
really despite the online mirror being
one of our less known feature it may be
one of the most important one in my mind
you should definitely check it out and
if you don't it's fine because it will
soon become unmissable starting from the
v2 where it will be enabled by default
going back to the things we did right
war space is also pretty high on the
list if you don't know them pretty well
they allow you to split your monolithic
applications into sub projects that can
live independently from each other while
still being able to cross-reference each
other you can see them as a kind of
declarative yawn link for example you
can see here that we've been able to
split our huge blob of dependencies into
smaller pieces one for the backend one
for the front end war spaces initially
came from the community but as a time
pass and we noticed how much they
improved our own project we decided to
make it a core feature annyeong and that
was a Garuda great idea given the
success they got we will be double down
our efforts to make them first-class
citizen as you will soon see finally the
last core value that we definitely
should mention is the overall user
experience it doesn't seem much but it's
actually a big reason why our users say
they use yarn the small things like
you run keyword not being needed or the
merge conflicts automatically being
resolved those things aren't the big
shiny things you typically on our site
but there are the comments that you use
every day the ones that shape your
workflow and that's something we keep in
mind when working on the v2 ok so now we
have to talk a bit about the elephant in
the room why are we even talking about
animate new major young release today
about alpha if you already use yawn in
your daily life regret success so how
would a new major release affect you do
we really have something significant to
bring to the table and if so what
something to realize is that young got
created in 2016
since then a lot of things happened for
one we released a lot of major features
war spaces in 2017 plug and play in 2018
zip loading is coming in 2019 and we go
to that later
our architecture needed refresh to say
stay up-to-date with all those new
concepts that didn't even existed when
y'all got created and to support the new
war flow they unlock additionally young
got initially created as an NPM clone as
such we inherited various behaviors that
don't mesh well with the user experience
we want to provide which as much as I
mentioned is something we really care
about so for those technical reasons we
need to build something new to build a
new modern foundation more suited to
what we had in mind but that's not the
only reason that the main reason in my
mind is that we wanted to give you more
power we wanted to make it easier for
you to contribute to young to write your
own features to fix what blocks you to
not have to rely on us after all yawn is
a community project we don't want to
work for you we want to work with you so
our architecture needed to reflect that
and for this reason we decided to make
it very modular so that you would be
able to write your own plugins in fact
most of the features in Yong 2 are
actually plugins that got aggregated
together in a single binary in the same
theme we moved our code base to a more
family our stack type script
and we hope that by doing this it will
decrease the time needed for you to
understand the pieces how they fit
together in such a way that you will be
able to help us maintain this critical
part of your infrastructure and it's
called extended scope to new hive now
enough about the abstract talk
let's Steve a bit into what the next
major version of yarn will concretely
bring to the table the first thing you
will notice is that we revamped the
output what young prince is how it
communicates with you and we wanted to
make it easier for you to figure out
what happens and I light the most
important information this translates
into important way first we know print
message codes that can be googled for
more details on what a specific message
means and in the case of errors how to
solve them secondly we are now using
colors with a specific purpose to
highlight the dynamic part of our
messages it's one of those very tiny
thing that I mentioned that happened to
matter a lot when you work with young
every day by using the colors that the
right place we aim to decrease the
cognitive overhead of using yawn you
won't have to fight to understand it the
v2 also comes with new commands you
might have heard about young create in
the v1 which allowed you to download and
run any package print things by the
world create well in the video we
decided to expand it and create and
build young DLX young DLX
very similar to its sibling an TX can
install packages from the registry
without mutating your local project it
allows you to run one of strips without
worrying about having to revert your
changes after a while the defect let's
see a quick demonstration of it so here
we have a JavaScript file which is a web
pack configuration and we want to minify
it usually we would have to add the mini
theatre sir into our package JSON
culture sir and then remove tercer from
the package ageism but by using DLX
you just have to run young dialects dear
sir and the name of the file and
will automatically download everything
that's needed and run it locally but
even better since we are using
plug-and-play it means that we don't
have to create a non modules anymore and
if we don't have to create a normal use
anymore then DLX at the second
invocation will be just as fast as it
can be because we will not have to fetch
the package again so if I run young the
elects cursor index the GS again it will
be super fast so that's four new
commands we have all the ones but we
also improved the existing ones various
changes were also made to make it easier
to work with mono repos or to fix
long-standing issues that we had young
hub can now upgrade package across all
your workspaces at once young link is
now able to properly resolve bill
dependencies even when you link an
external package into your current
project yon are and various other
comments
no except an interacting flag that
instructs yon to ask you for advice in
various situations and it's not only a
toy the interactive mode for example
allows you to quickly reuse a version of
a package that another one of your
workspaces is already using you don't
need to grab into your package JSON
anymore - fin - find that out
speaking about dripping into packages on
we aren't releasing constraints wouldn't
it be nice if you could just check that
your project obey some rules like
linting some kind of BS lint but for
package JSON we thought so too and one
of our newest additions are constraints
constraints are basically links rules
written in Prolog and a Java Script that
might be surprising but Prolog makes
them extremely small and powerful in the
example you see on the screen you can
see a simple rule that just forbids all
of our workspaces from adding battle
listed as a regular dependency versus a
development dependency in fact with only
two more lines we could extend this to
automate
move the dependency within the
dependency dev dependency field
constraints are very powerful and have
many usages you can see some of the
screen and we will provide some recipes
in our documentation to get started but
you will quickly see that it's super
easy to write new ones that are directly
adapted to your use case now we can see
them in practice a bit so here I have a
project with two workspaces my front end
and my back end both of my front end on
my back end or depending on lodash
except that they depend on different
version of ladach additionally both of
this project are actually type strips
and should probably depend on TS leaver
but they don't so it would be nice if
there was a way to detect all those
problems and fix them as best as we can
yon as a new command that is young
constraints check when yarn constraints
check is called it will validate the
project against the defined rules so in
this case you can see that it has been
able to detect that back-end and
front-end mass depend on T asleep and
that they depend on conflicting versions
of lodash now if I run yawn constraints
fix yawn will automatically try to fix
all the problems that it detects and can
fix so in this case for example you can
see that it has been able to add ta
sleep to the dependencies it hasn't been
able to correct the mismatch in lo -
because it's ambiguous it doesn't know
which one you want to use in order to
fix those kind of issues well you just
have the gold old yawn R if you run yawn
ad with the interactive mode as I
mentioned before yawn will ask you which
version of yawn you want to use amongst
multiple possible ones in this situation
it is smart enough to tell you that
lodash is already used in - workspaces
so which one do you want to use and by
using this feature you don't have to
think about how should I fix the problem
oh that's how you just have to validate
and yawn will automatically continue and
do its stuff
if you run the unconstraint check again
you will see that all the errors have
been properly fixed and if we check the
packages on everything has been applied
now something else that we can't do with
constraints because of how powerful they
are is use them as a query engine now
this is a bit interesting by using your
constraints query you get to ask Yong
what do you know about my project so for
example in this case by using one simple
query I'm able to ask you to tell me all
the dependencies and all the ranches in
all of my workspaces but I want I can't
be more precise if I want to I just have
to specify one of the parameter and Yun
will be able to just filter those so
that's the problem that that's the power
of the constraints another feature that
we are working on and that is maybe the
biggest feature that we will ship is
zero install zero install isn't actually
a feature is more of a concept and it's
more aimed for applications than
libraries even though they work for both
the idea is never run Jonnie style again
that might remind you something so the
idea behind this is that if a code needs
to run this code will fail even though
we try our best to make a package
manager that never fails from time to
time we are not free of making a bug or
making a mistake and it will crash at
some point or may if it's not us maybe
it's on you for example maybe at some
point your file system will become
read-only and then running yon style
will not work that actually happened to
me before so in order for something to
work every time it doesn't need to it
must not run so is it with zero in style
the concept is simple you just add all
your yarn files into the repository you
do and then you don't need to run your
stuff because everything will be there
so now I know what you think you
saying that committing the non-muslims
directory is bad but remember that with
plug-and-play we don't have an
unbalanced directory anymore and plugin
place by default in the v2 and the
problem with committing unknown models
was that non models contain 20000 text
files you might remember I mentioned zip
loading before with young - instead of
generating and Nan models instead of
generating an unpatched cache we just
download each package that you use and
we store them within your project or
elsewhere if you don't want to which
means that for each package that you use
you will have exactly one archive and
that's peanuts for wishes to support
that's very easy we actually discuss it
with github force before before breaking
their infra and they told us it would be
fine so what do Ciro installed bring to
the table cat mentioned it is improve
the developer experience by a large
factor we don't have to run Y on Sal
between git pull git checkout git rebase
all those comments peer reviewers also
know which package have been handed
because they just have to look at the
files change and see what what troubles
have been added into the project it's
faster simpler and stay more stable for
deployments because again you don't have
to run yawn at all so there is no risk
of young crushing in production
additionally you will always have
exactly the same state on production as
you have on development because that's
the guarantee we provide if it works
luckily it will work in production
additionally it allows you to skip the
CI configuration step so in this case we
can see a quick demonstration of zero
install so you can see that we have a
small project that is using webpack 3
and we would like to update to webpack 4
so we create a new branch and here we
will just run yon add web pack for so
yon is now running downloading all the
dependencies as it always did and if we
do after that git status we
something very interesting but first
yeah you can see that webpack got
updated correctly of course and now if
we run git status you can see something
interesting instead of having an on
models we have as I mentioned one zip
for each package if we commit all this
then we have everything we need in order
to run our applications so now let's say
that suddenly a project manager comes
into your room and tells you hey we need
to fix this problem on master and it
needs to be done now
so here you need to switch gear switch
quickly into the web pack three branch
make your challenge and commit it but
just after switching you don't have to
run Yun itself because everything is
exactly like it should be your project
is always in a good State
and once you're done you just have to
switch back on your peer of web pack for
and everything will work just the same
by having this workflow and simplifying
context switches it makes you much more
productive because then you can work on
multiple features at any point in time
in fact it's super useful for me as as a
young maintainer because I can quickly
check out all the pure peers that are
submitted to you and see of the world or
fix them myself if there is something
that need to be fixed something that was
before very painful because I had to be
careful about which to in which state
was my project is now super easy
in fact Yan to itself is using your inch
cell so for example here you can find
that I'm cloning the yarn repository so
it is a bit slower than it would be if
you didn't have those turbines inside
your repository but it's still much
faster than it would be if you were to
clone your repository and then run your
install so in the end there's a kind of
balance here and yeah because we bounced
here so the clone is about to finish and
starting from now you can use any
comment that you would typically use so
for example here I can run the unit test
for yarn I don't have to run your
instyle in order to install JSTOR
everything is always there so it makes
it much easier for our contributors to
jump in into the project they just have
to clone and run the common they don't
have to think more about it so let's
recap a bit we have an improved logging
we have new comments we have improved
commands we have added packages on
linting we have removed the need to run
yarn in style that that happens to be
worth a major bump right and of course
that's just the tip of the iceberg this
is only a 30 minute talk and there's
only so much that we can discuss here
fortunately we have a much more
comprehensive chat log on our github
repository I encourage you to look at it
to learn more about what's coming the
video is still Flag experimental but
it's starting to be stable enough that
it's a good candidate to bootstrap your
visual project the official release is
still to be determined but we're aiming
somewhere in the second album of 2019
once we will have ensure the transition
path is as smooth as possible
a big thanks should go to our
contributors of course but the v2 in
particular we've had a pleasure to
welcome various new people who simply
stepped in into the project and improved
what the feature they liked I said young
is a community project at the beginning
of my talk and I really meant it we are
always looking for new contributors more
than that we're ready to go the extra
mile and I help you get started
yan is a huge project with a huge reach
huge impact but we still aim to make it
approachable by anyone plus we have cool
t-shirts for the video if you contribute
to the project of course so I will now
leave you I hope you enjoyed this talk
please come ask your question when you
see me in the hall I'll be thrilled to
share more about the work we do thank
you and have a good evening
[Applause]
[Music]